me piden que factor hice 25 x cuadrada
menos 30 x + 9 lo primero que quiero que
te des cuenta es que el lado del x
cuadrada no tenemos un 1 tenemos un 25
pero podemos factorizar esto por
agrupación y antes de proseguir lo
primero que quiero que veas es que no
tenemos un factor común 25 y 30 tienen
como factor como un 5 pero ya con 9 no y
39 tienen como factor común el 3 pero el
25 no entonces se me ocurre que tal vez
y sólo tal vez esta expresión que nos
piden factorizar se pueda ver como un
binomio al cuadrado perfecto porque
fíjate que 25 x cuadrada tiene raíz
cuadrada exacta y 9 también tiene raíz
cuadrada exacta entonces vamos a ver qué
pasaba con las expresiones que se veían
de este estilo cuando yo tenía algo de
la forma x + b que multiplicaba a x +
veo a x + b al cuadrado
x + b elevado al cuadrado pues esto es
lo mismo que multiplicar a x más bx más
bien entonces vamos a escribirlo así y
vamos a realizar la multiplicación de un
binomio por un binomio y que me va a
quedar a x por a x me va a quedar a
cuadrada x cuadrada entonces hay que
escribirlo aquí a cuadrada x cuadrado y
después tengo que sumarle a x volver a x
por b es lo mismo que a b x y después
tengo b que multiplica a x y esto
también es a b x entonces lo voy a poner
aquí a b x y por último tengo b que
multiplica a ver que es b cuadrado y
esto todavía lo podemos simplificar un
poco me va a quedar a cuadrada x
cuadrada y después tengo a b x más a b x
es lo mismo que dos veces a b x ya esto
le sumamos b cuadrada y bueno esta es la
expresión equivalente que nos queda al
tener la expresión a x + b elevado al
cuadrado
y bueno si yo quisiera o si de pura
casualidad pensara que esto es un
binomio al cuadrado perfecto entonces 25
x cuadrado
a cuadrada x cuadrada dos veces a b x
tendrá que ser menos 30 x ive cuadrada
tendrá que ser 9 o dicho de otra manera
a cuadrada tendrá que ser 25 y b
cuadrada tendría que ser 9 b cuadrada
tele que 09 yo estoy suponiendo que tal
vez se vea de esta manera no pero
solamente tiene que ser un mi nombre
cuadrado perfecto pero bueno la raíz
cuadrada de 25 es más menos 5 y la raíz
cuadrada de 9 es más menos 3 y sería muy
bueno revisar que aquí en medio
estuviera dos veces a ver dos veces a b
x o dos veces
avn es más podemos decir que dos veces a
b es igual a menos 32 veces a b es igual
a menos 30 y vamos a ver qué
posibilidades tenemos con esto dos veces
de igual a menos 30 y si dividido ambos
lados entre 2 me va a quedar que abel es
lo mismo que 15 menos 15 y entonces qué
posibilidades tengo 5 x 3 me dan 15 pero
fíjate que necesito que los signos
coincidan también por lo tanto no puedo
tomar el valor de 5 positivos
es negativo dejemos cristo aquí puede
ser que valga 5 y bbva -3 o en su dado
caso que sea al revés que a valga menos
5 y b valga 3 positivo entonces lo voy a
escribir aquí puede valer 5 positivo y
en su dado caso b puede valer menos 3
porque fíjate que 5 x menos 3 me va a
dar menos 15 hasta aquí vamos bien y me
otras posibilidades que valgan menos 5 y
b valga 3 positivo menos 5 x + 3 me da
15 negativo y aquí es cuando nos ponemos
bastante contentos porque entonces si en
efecto es un binomio al cuadrado
perfecto ojo no forzosamente tenía que
hacerlo pero nos acabamos de dar cuenta
que si cumple esta ecuación entonces nos
puede quedar 5 x menos tres elevado al
cuadrado 5x menos tres elevado al
cuadrado o en su dado caso podemos ver
la otra opción la otra opciones es que a
valga menos 5 y b valga 3 positivo es
decir me quedaría algo como menos 5 x +
3 - 5 x más tres elevado al cuadrado y
bueno me gustaría saber si estas dos
expresiones son lo mismo porque yo tengo
dos resuelto
2 y parece ser que esto es un poco
ambiguo pero si te das cuenta en el
resultado derecho yo puedo factorizar un
-1 fíjate bien si factores menos 1 me va
a quedar la siguiente expresión menos 1
que multiplica a quien menos 5 x entre
menos 1 me da 5 x positivo y 3 entre
menos 1 me da menos 3 y todo esto
elevado al cuadrado
y bueno si separamos los cuadrados me va
a quedar menos 1 elevado al cuadrado por
5 x menos tres elevado al cuadrado pero
menos uno al cuadrado es uno entonces me
quedaría el resultado exactamente lo
mismo que tengo a la izquierda 5x menos
3 elevado al cuadrado y entonces nos
acabamos de dar cuenta que esta es la
solución de la factorización de la
expresión que yo tenía que arriba